I know the recent cyberpunk 2077 update
allowed for way more customization in
builds but I wasn't expecting this this
is from Rea 7500 on the cyberp subreddit
and this is such a cool play now when
you drive of course you can actually
jump out of vehicles properly and there
is a proper animation if you kind of
landing on the floor and then you can
slow down time if you have certain
things
equipped assassinate a bunch of people
and actually have the time to make it
back to your car and continue onwards
there is so much more creativity in the
game now that you can like really get
into the nitty-gritty of exactly how you
want your character to play out or
exactly what kind of build you want like
I just think it looks so cool